il cette affaire de dopage ou en tout
cas de trafic de produits dopants
empoisonne le tour de france depuis le
début certains parlent quand d'autres
observent un silence gêné et prudent
florent gautreau et alain poirier visage
fermé
long silence et sourires de circonstance
drôle d'ambiance pour un tour de france
l'affairé festina a jeté un froid dans
le peloton car si les coéquipiers de
virenque sont en première ligne tous les
coureurs se sentent concernés la
première semaine du tour d'ordinaire
très joyeuse ressemble un long chemin de
croix
oui assez pâle fois ça a cassé quelque
chose dont le départ en irlande
ensuite d'affaires combine on est pas on
n'est pas dans un marché euphorique du
doigt les performances restent dans
l'ombre et la polémique éclate au grand
jour les coureurs ne supporte pas la
suspicion dont ils font l'objet et qu'on
entend l'expression tous dopés le monde
du vélo
un réflexe d'autodéfense 7,4 cette crise
parce que autrement qu'à sauter tout le
monde
autre était content d'être africain à
17h30 jean marie leblanc apprend que
bruno roussel va être entendu par la
police
on en oublierait presque que le maillot
jaune a encore changé des pôles
la course passe au second plan c'est le
sort de l'équipe festina qui est en jeu
on a cherché à nous faire exclure les
coureurs ou à nous inciter à pousser des
qui fait tenir en dehors du tour de
france il n'en a jamais été question
tu t'étais profondément injuste pour les
coureurs
il ne méritait pas ça pendant les
affaires le tour continue les coureurs
cours
les courageux s'échapper les sprinteurs
sprint mais le coeur n'y est plus
vraiment est déjà occulté par la coupe
du monde le tour de france fait
maintenant parler de lui dans la
rubrique des faits divers l'épreuve
reine du cyclisme mondial traverse la
une de ces crises les plus graves et les
rumeurs de retrait de l'équipe festina
ne sont pas là pour améliorer l'ambiance
dans le peloton